>> WATCHING THIS YEAR'S SHORT
DOCUMENTARY FILMS, I'M REMINDED
BY HOW MUCH IMPACT GOOD
STORYTELLING CAN HAVE AT ANY LENGTH.
"COLETTE" INTRODUCES US TO A
90-YEAR-OLD FRENCH RESISTANCE
FIGHTER, WHOSE THEN 17-YEAR-OLD
BROTHER, ALSO IN THE RESISTANCE,
WAS SENT TO A GERMAN
CONCENTRATION CAMP BY THE NAZIS.
“A CONCERTO IS A CONVERSATION”
IS A GORGEOUS TRIBUTE TO A
GRANDFATHER WHO MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR HIS FAMILY TO DREAM THE
BIGGEST OF DREAMS.
“HUNGER WARD” TAKES US INSIDE A
CLINIC IN YEMEN.
THE RESULT IS AS DIZZYING AND
AS DISORIENTING AS WAR ITSELF.
EMBEDDED INSIDE THE HONG KONG
PROTESTS FOR "DO NOT SPLIT,"
THE FILMMAKERS' APPROACH IS
DEEPLY COLLABORATIVE.
SOPHIA NAHLI ALLISON'S
EXPERIMENTAL DOCUMENTARY "A LOVE
SONG FOR LATASHA," IS A
MEDITATION ON LIFE AND JOY IN
THE SOUTH CENTRAL NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE SHE SPENT HER CHILDHOOD.
AND THE ACADEMY AWARD FOR BEST
DOCUMENTARY SHORT GOES TO --
“COLETTE”
ANTHONY GIACCHINO
AND ALICE DOYARD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
TO THE ACADEMY, I HOPE THE
ACTORS IN THE ROOM DON'T MIND
THAT I HAVE SOMETHING
WRITTEN DOWN HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PEOPLE IN THE ACADEMY.
TODAY IS COLETTE'S BIRTHDAY.
SHE WAS BORN JUST
22 DAYS BEFORE
THE VERY FIRST OSCARS IN 1929.
SO, I IMAGINE IT MUST HAVE BEEN A,
PROBABLY ABOUT A
CROWD ABOUT THIS BIG, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW?
WHEN WE GOT NOMINATED, SHE TOLD
US THAT, OR SHE REMINDED US THAT
THE POWER OF DOCUMENTARY
FILMMAKING ENSURED THAT HER
BROTHER, JEAN-PIERRE, WAS,
AS SHE PUT IT, NO LONGER LOST
IN THE NIGHT AND FOG OF THE
NAZI CONCENTRATION CAMP SYSTEM.
AND I WANT TO SAY, I THINK IT'S
THE -- THAT SAME POWER OF THE
DOCUMENTARY STORYTELLING THAT IS
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THE MEMORY,
COURAGE, AND RESILIENCE OF
LATASHA HARLINS, HORACE BOWERS,
THE INNOCENT CHILDREN OF YEMEN,
AND THE PROTESTERS IN HONG KONG
ARE NOT FORGOTTEN.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHY WE DO THIS.
THAT'S WHY WE MAKE THESE FILMS.
SO THANK YOU.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THESE
STORIES AND THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN HONORED TONIGHT.
AND I ALSO WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK,
OF COURSE, COLETTE AND LUCIE.
I WANT TO THANK OUR AMAZING E.P.,
PETER HIRSCHMANN, AT ELECTRONIC ARTS.
EVERYONE AT ELECTRONIC ARTS,
AND RESPAWN, AND OCULUS
ESPECIALLY VINCE
DUSTY, AND LAURA,
AND OUR PRODUCERS,
ANNIE SMALL AND AARON MATTHEWS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TO THE GUARDIANS, CHARLIE
PHILLIPS, JESS GORMLEY, AND
LINDSAY POULTON.
WE SHARE THIS AWARD WITH YOU.
>> AND I JUST ADD SOMETHING,
THIS AWARD IS A TRIBUTE, AND
THIS FILM IS A TRIBUTE TO WOMEN
EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD OF ANY
AGES, THAT -- WHO ARE JOINING
HANDS AND FIGHT FOR JUSTICE.
[ SPEAKING FRENCH ]
THANK YOU.